first in the nation for Democrats
there's immense Pride that South
Carolina has replaced Iowa and New
Hampshire as the traditional kickoff
States we need Florence to turn up this
is seen as a rallying call at Grassroots
meetings of the democratic party like
this one addressed by the party's
national leader people are going to come
out and vote uh people are excited we're
going all over the state and um um
really lot of energy right now the
Bedrock of Biden's support is in this
room he deserves it he's done a lot he's
a good person he has a good heart and
it's he wants to work for the people
okay it's Joe Biden versus Donald Trump
and we start to see the contrast in in
in both of them they said well Joe Biden
did do some things he didn't do it all
but yeah let's give him four more years
to see can he do what we want him to do
but there's less certainty among a
younger generation and growing
resentment that Democrats take the
African-American vote for granted get
together with the belief that Biden has
not fulfilled 2020 promises I believe
that he showed us a vision of what we
wanted to hear and when it came down to
actually keeping his promise on that
Vision it completely went out of the
door ceas during a recent campaign
speech in Charleston Biden was
interrupted by calls for a ceasefire in
Gaza the administration's unquestioning
support of Israel's war has sparked deep
Ang among young Democrats Victoria
Jordan points to the massive economic
gains made under Biden his promotion of
woman of color to the country's courts
and executive but argues his support of
a genocide could be punished at the
polls especially college students myself
included um asking for that ceasefire
asking for you know more understanding
of what's going on overseas not only
affects you know older Generations but
it just in as much if not more affects
us younger Generations cuz we're
inheriting all of
this latest figures indicate that nearly
15 million jobs have been created since
Biden took office unemployment has
dropped below 4% and inflation is at
near prepandemic levels the voters of
South Carolina will decide whether this
is evidence of a job well done Mike
Hannah alera South
Carolina make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
zero